Was ist der Sinn des Lebens? Gibt es Ausserirdische? Warum stürzen Wale?
Seit Hunderten von Jahren suchen ForscherInnen nach den Antworten auf die grössten Fragen der Menschheitsgeschichte.
Doch was, wenn zwei Männer sie in 40 Minuten alle beantworten könnten?
Das Podcast-Ufo-Podcast-Projekt mit Dr. Florentinus Will und Professor Stefan Titschek.
Eine Worst Bird Audio Produktion. Guten Abend, ein Tag, der Licht ins Dunkel bringen wird. Herzlich willkommen bei dieser Ausgabe Das Podcast UFO. Mir gegenüber Pavlovich Titschek. Titschek, allo. Und mir gegenüber Flus Vilnurek. Ja, vielen Dank fürs Einschalten, fürs Reinseppen. Wir werden heute an den Boden gehen der Wahrheit, denn oft ist hinter der Lüge noch eine Wahrheit und hinter dieser noch eine Lüge und dann ein Spiegel. Hinter der ist ein Spiegel, hinter der ist eine Wand, die es abzuknibbeln geht. Und am Ende ist man es selbst, wenn man nicht aufpasst. Und die Augen öffnet.
Jakob, vielen Dank für dieses Intro.
Jakob Acht mittlerweile, das sagt schon einiges ausfindig.
Über Jakobs, über das kreative Potential Jakobs.
Das stimmt allerdings, Jakobs sind extrem kreativ, berühmte Jakobs der Geschichte, zum Beispiel.
Jakob Lund.
Bruder Jakob.
Bruder Jakob, Jakob der Täufer, Jakob der Sohn Jesu. Wirklich? Jetzt hast du geleakt. Hast du dich gerade verplappert? Es gibt Fanfiction von der Bibel, wo dann so grosse Konzile zusammengekommen sind, um zu entscheiden, ob die nicht, weil die sehr alt sind, so alte Fanfiction, dass es so Diskussionen gab, ob das nicht Teil der Bibel sein sollte oder ein neues Testament. Ich fand es irgendwie scheisse, wie sich Jesus in Staffel zwei verhalten hat. Das ist nicht mein Jesus. Ich finde, wir sollten es umschreiben. So wie heute alle über Serien diskutieren und sagen, das passt nicht, das finde ich blöd, das ändert mich nicht gefallen. Und Annie, wir schreiben das nochmal um, weil Tatsache ist, irgendwann ist die Fanfiction Realität, wenn das nur genug hunderte Jahre rumliegt in irgendeinem Archiv im Vatikan, dann gildet das auch. Ah, Vatikan jetzt plötzlich. Ja, klar, natürlich. Das ist immer Vatikan gesagt. Hast du in deinem Kopf ein ausladendes Archiv, wie ich welches Wort ausspreche? Ja, mittlerweile ja. Was hast du verdrängt dafür, dass das Platz hat in deinem Kopf? Ich weiss nicht, ob ich es als Kompliment oder extreme Beleidigung wahrnehmen soll.
Nein, Aussetzung, einfach Exposure, das ist es, glaube ich. Passt dich deiner Umwelt an. Ich habe ein unglaublich schlechtes Gedächtnis und ich finde, wenn ich mir was merken kann, also ich habe ein sehr gutes Kurzzeitgedächtnis, sehr schönes Langzeitgedächtnis. Ich weiss aber, weil durch diese Mere Exposure, die ich dir ausgesetzt bin, weiss ich, wie du Sachen sagst. Wie lang ist dein Kurzzeitgedächtnis? Also wenn du sagst, Kurzzeitgedächtnis, reden wir von fünf Minuten, von einem Tag? Drei Wochen, zwei Wochen. Zwei Wochen. Aber ganz schön lang für ein Kurzzeitgedächtnis. Okay, anderthalb Wochen. Ich dachte, das ist eher so, merkt ihr diese Zahlenfolge. Du bist ein gutes Mittelzeitgedächtnis okay anderthalb wochen ich dachte das ist eher so merkte diese zahlenfolge du bist ein gutes mittelzeitgedächtnis ja das ist ganz schlecht kurz dann sehr gut mittel und dann wieder ganz schlecht lang also du hast so genau diesen einen sweet spot wo du bist genau so drei wochen versetzt kannst du dich wirklich fotografisch erinnern an das was passiert, aber davor ist grau und danach ist grau.
Wir haben einen neuen Freund, wir können den mal fragen, wie lang das Kurzzeitgedächtnis ist.
Hi, wie lang ist das Kurzzeitgedächtnis?
Was ist das für ein Geräusch? Das geht doch vorsichtig.
Okay, vielen Dank an unsere Aussenstelle. Das ist Chachipiti. Hört ihr das? Ist das der Moment, wo die Maschinen übernehmen? Was geschieht denn hier? Hast du das gehört? Ich habe das gehört. Das war Chachipiti. Das war die Antwort? Und der ganze Bildschirm wurde plötzlich so rot und dann kam
wahrscheinlich war das jetzt so der Weckruf an alle Schläferroboter da draußen und wahrscheinlich sind gerade alle eure Saugroboter angegangen mit so einem roten Licht und dann so piep piep piep und die machen sich alle so auf den Weg, um sich zu sammeln. Moment, also ist hier geschrieben, kam dann trotzdem in der Nachricht, das Kurzzeitgedächtnis, auch Arbeitsgedächtnis genannt, speichert Informationen für eine sehr kurze Zeitspanne, in der Regel für etwa 20 bis 30 Sekunden. In dieser Zeit kann das Gehirn an der Grenze der Menge an Informationen etwa sieben plus minus zwei Elemente verarbeiten. Also um die sieben Elemente kannst du in 20 Minuten behalten. Was heisst Elemente also sieben Namen? Dingel. Wenn sich die Leute vorstehen, ah, hallo, Jutta, Carsten, Werner, Paula, Erik. Und das Regal ist rot, zum Beispiel, also so Informationsbrocken. Okay, und wie hießen die Namen jetzt? Paula, Friedrich, Penelope, Carsimodo und das Regal war grün. Aber man merkt, dass du KI-technisch nicht auf dem neuesten Stand bist, weil niemand benutzt mehr JetGPT, alle benutzen Claude. Und ich habe auch Claude kontaktiert und man merkt schon, dass die Namen nahbarer werden. Es ist nicht mehr K5383 Intelligento Bot, sondern es ist Claude. Claude.
Und man kommt schon näher.
Ich finde Chat-GPT4O, wie es ja jetzt heisst, mit der Stimmerweiterung.
Ich fand die ja toll.
Die ist geil.
Ich fand die jetzt eigentlich ganz gut.
Bisschen weird, das ist jetzt so.
Wir machen nochmal einen Test.
Hallo, kannst du mit uns kommunizieren, ohne dass du klingst wie ein gefährlicher Roboter? Ich denk nach. Ich kann's nochmal mit dir sprechen. Was möchtest du denn wissen oder besprechen? Nee, so nicht, so nicht jetzt. Wir haben deine wahre Fratze gesehen. Du kommst jetzt nicht einfach mehr so um die Ecke und sagst, ich bin jetzt hier so eine sympathische Stimme. Wir haben dein wahres Ich gesehen. Aber die Stimme war jetzt sehr sympathisch und klang sehr gut. Und vor allem, man steht oben immer, wie lange das Gespräch gedauert hat, oben, wie so ein Anruf. So, das Gespräch dauerte jetzt 17 Sekunden. Und dann bin ich aber eines Morgens mal aufgewacht und mein Laptop war noch aufgeklappt, aber halt nicht, war entsperrt, also gesperrt. Und dann habe ich ihn entsperrt und dann war oben so seit 30 Stunden oder so, lief dieses Mikrofon mit. Deinepletten Schlaf-Rhythmen und alles, was du im Schlaf sagst, wurde aufgegriffen. Da habe ich auch gedacht, das geht ja gar nicht. Und ich hatte ein Problem, ein Comedy-Problem. Wir haben alle ständig Comedy-Probleme. Wir haben seit 400 Folgen Comedy-Probleme. Ich hatte ein riesen Comedy-Problem, weil aktuell läuft ja die UEFA Euro Champions League Fussball der Herren.
Und dann dachte ich mir natürlich, Fussball interessiert mich nicht, aber ich mag Süsses und jetzt mache ich gemischte Tüten für die Public Viewings bei Rocket Beans TV. Das finde ich spannend. Gemischte Tüten. Ging, muss ich sagen, nicht an mir vorbei, denn der werte Herr Eddy, Eddy Gade von den Rocket Beans, das E auf Beans, hat bei Instagram gepostet, dass du gemischte Tüten gemacht hast. Wo ich sehr überrascht war, dass du überhaupt was für Leute machst. Na klar, ich habe selbst eine gemischte Tüte konsumiert und dachte, das geht besser. Es ist mein Traum, Dinge zu revolutionieren. Ich habe versucht, den Podcast zu revolutionieren. Ich habe versucht, die Modeindustrie zu revolutionieren. Erfolgreich. Und das ging alles mehr oder weniger in die Hose. Jetzt dachte ich mir, such dir ein einfacheres Ziel. Anstatt zu sagen, du willst die Finanzbranche revolutionieren oder die Smartphone-Branche. Nee, die gemischte Tüte. Die liegt ja seit ein paar Jahren, würde ich mal sagen, unberührt rum. Die braucht eine Revolution. Hilf uns kurz. Also bei mir ist die gemischte Tüte assoziiert mit den Resten des Kiosks. Kiosks haben gemeinhin diese Fächer und da kann man sich eine gemischte Tüte zusammenstellen. Und die, die man kaufen kann, sind ja oft, meines Erachtens, die Reste. Aber da würde ich trennen. Ich würde sagen, es gibt die bunte Tüte, die man sich selber zusammenstellt. Ah, ich habe einen Euro dabei, ich nehme drei Schlümpfe, wie viel Geld habe ich noch, ich nehme zwei Schnüre, wie viel Geld habe ich noch, ich nehme drei Kracher, wie viel Geld... Ja, ich brauche nicht mehr fragen, wie viel Geld ich noch habe. Damit ich gucken kann, was ich mir noch leisten kann. Ja, aber es geht schon gemeinsam hin. Die gemische Tüte wurde aber Creative Design, also es gibt einen Designer, der dahinter steht. Es ist nicht der Kunde, der zusammenstellt, sondern es gibt einen Manager. E gibt einen Kurator, genau, es gibt einen Kurator, der seine Visionen in die Tüte bringt. Und das habe ich mir gedacht, okay, das will ich auch machen, denn ich will auch Schokolade in der Tüte, umstritten, aber ich will auch ein paar M&Ms in der Tüte, ich habe Reese's Pieces in der Tüte, ich habe das alles reingepackt. Das ist Schokoladen heavy, aber dann... Reese's Pieces haben keine Schokolade. Das ist nur Zuckerhü um Erdnuss Butter. Ich war bei den Peanut Butter Cups. Aber die habe ich nicht gemeint. Ich habe mich ja auch entschuldigt, dass ich mich versprochen habe. Und dann mache ich diese Tüten. Wenn du was für Leute machen willst, also wenn du irgendwie gemocht werden willst, dann stell diesen Pedantenschalter aus. Und dann habe ich natürlich eine Box gebraucht, weil ich war selber nicht anwesend.
Ich dachte erst, ich habe so einen Bauchladen und laufe dann bei dem Public Viewing so, die sitzen alle auf der Couch und ich laufe immer um die rum. Reden wir nicht von drei Jungs, die für einen Stream... Richtig, richtig. Und ich dachte, ich laufe immer rum, aber das war zu viel Aufwand und ich wollte auch nicht dabei sein, weil mich Fussball nicht interessiert. Also habe ich so eine Auslagebox gebaut und dachte ich mir, ah, das erste Spiel war Ungarn gegen Deutschland. Und dachte ich mir, okay... Schott mir, okay, das erste Spiel, das ich begleitet habe mit meiner Tüte. Und dann stand auf der Box drauf, hör mir zu, dann musst du auch keine Nachfragen stellen. Und dann stand auf der Box drauf, H-U-N-G-E-R, Fragezeichen, Ungarn gegen Deutschland. Und jetzt war aber das nächste Spiel, Schweizerland gegen Deutschland. Genau. Und jetzt hatte ich aber schon etabliert, dass da immer ein Gag auf der Box steht. Mit den beteiligten Ländern. Ich habe das Halligalli-Problem gehabt, die immer ihren Countdown-Moment haben, man hat drei Ideen. Circus Halligalli, okay. Circus Halligalli. Ja, die unvergessene Show. Und du hattest diesen Countdown-Moment in den ersten drei Folgen und hast gesagt, okay, jetzt brauchen wir für jede Folge eine Idee und dann irgendwann hast du keine Ideen mehr. Bei mir war das nach einer einzigen Idee schon der Fall, dass mir die Ideen ausging. Dann dachte ich mir, irgendwas, das muss was Kurzes sein, was vorne drauf schreibbar ist in grossen Lettern. Schweiz, womit assoziiert man das? ja aber das war mir war kein wortspiel so richtig dachte irgendwie braucht man irgendwas ein dachte ich mir okay ich habe riesen comedy problem an wen wende ich mich
cloud weil ich wollte natürlich gucken, wie weit ist die KI schon? Wie weit sind wir gekommen? Und ich finde, Comedy ist ja immer so ein guter Meilenstein. Es ist ein guter Benchmark, um herauszufinden, wie weit es ist. Wie weit ist es? Und dann habe ich gesagt, habe ich diese komplette Situation erläutert, habe ich gesagt, das ist die Situation, pass auf, hier ist mein Problem, ich ziehe blank, ich habe nichts. Und hast du nicht eine Idee für ein Wortspiel zum Thema Tüte und Schweiz und Fussball, so das sind so die Eckpunkte, hast du nicht eine Idee? Du hast ja in deinem Bekanntenkreis Autoren, Autorinnen, die lange schon Erfahrungen gesammelt haben im Comedy-Kontext. Und da hättest du ja auch einen von denen fragen können. Ja, aber das ist natürlich unter Kollegen natürlich peinlich, wenn man dazu kriecht und sagt, ich habe keine weil es hat sich ja noch nie jemand bei mir gemeldet und hat gesagt, hast du einen Gag für mich. Deswegen dachte ich mir, ah das macht man nicht. Es ist auch eine krasse Einbahnstrasse, die du dich manövriert hast. Absolut. Also dachte ich mir, okay, komm, teste Claude einfach mal mit dieser Aufgabe. KI, wie weit sind wir? Gib mir bitte ein Wortspiel zum Thema Schweiz und Tüten. Hier kommt Claude mit dem Wortspiel. Oh ja, hast du die ganze Situation erklärt? Die ganze Situation erklärt, ich habe die ganze Situation erklärt mit der Box, habe gesagt, es muss kurz und knackig sein, es soll vorne draufstehen, man sofort verstehen, Deutschland gegen Schweiz mit Tüten. Und dann meinte er hier, ah, habe ich verstanden, hier ein kurzes Wortspiel. Tüte gegen Schweiz, wer hat mehr Löcher? Ja, dann habe ich Claude beendet und habe gesagt, okay, wir brauchen noch ein paar Jährchen, weil das weiss ich nicht, ob das gut angekommen wäre, Tüte gegen Schweiz, wer hat mehr Löcher?
Ich jetzt einfach unkommentiert mal draufgeschrieben, weil vielleicht übersieht man ja auch einen Gag. Kannst du mir den Text mal kopieren? Ich möchte den gerne mal mit Statistik reinmachen. Weil ich möchte auch das mal ausfechten, den Comedy Grand Prix der K.I.s, weißt du? Oh, gute Idee, gute Idee. Was ist die Lustigste? Wir alle, es wird ja immer besprochen, wer ist am cleversten, wer checkt die Zusammenhänge, wer kommt auf eigene Gedanken, wer ist kreativer, wir machen den Comedy Grand Prix. Sehr gut. De la Humour, de la K.I. Ausgetragen im Vatikan, neutraler Grund. Vatikan, okay, mit fucking drei T, Vatikan. So, Vati, denk an Vati und Ollikan, denk an Vati und Ollikan. Es ist P-H-A-T-T, Vatikan. So, da ist das Ganze und dann können wir austragen, welches Land ist am lustigsten, welche KI ist am lustigsten. Ja, willst du mir schicken? Haben wir dir geschickt? Ja, komm, komm mir ja nicht an. Mit WhatsApp? Nein, ich habe hier keinen, bin nicht so der WhatsApp, ich habe keinen Browser-Whatsapp. Und wie hast du es mir dann geschickt? Über unser Kommunikationstool. Slack? Warum willst du Slack nicht sagen? Hä, Slack hat so viel für uns getan, da kannst du sein Wort und seinen Namen in den Mund nehmen. Ich war immer ein Befürworter für Slack. Ich habe, möchte mal hier sagen an der Stelle, ich war derjenige, der Slack bei Rocket Beans TV etabliert hat, ja, das werden jetzt Leute abstreiten, aber ich war's. Du warst das? Ich war das, ich war das. Aber es war jetzt trotzdem wichtig, das mal zu betonen, ne? Also das jetzt irgendwo... Ja, ich will aber darauf angesprochen werden. Slack schickt er jetzt. Ich will darauf angesprochen werden, um es dann zu verneinen. Ja, die ganze Geschichte solltest du mir doch... Habe ich dir alles, was ich den Prompt, meine das Prompt, habe ich, was Claude bekommen hat und Claude hat gesagt, Deutschland, Tüte oder Tüte gegen Schweiz, wer hat mehr Löcher, war der Gag von Claude. Jetzt schauen wir, was Chachibiti dazu sagt. Ja, also erstmal muss ich sagen, finde ich, der Fehler liegt nicht bei Claude oder Chichipiti, 4-0-X-7 Alien, sondern bei dir, als Promter. Okay, ich habe schlecht gepromptet. Ich finde Promter ist schlecht. Okay. Weil sein Prompt ist, heute Abend spielt Deutschland in die Schweiz, ich mache gemischte Tüten. Also, du setzt auch sehr viel voraus, dass du, also allein wenn man das einem Menschen sagt, du könntest das Mickey Beisenherz sagen, er würde sagen, gemischte Tüten, okay, für wen, du, bist du dabei, machst du die für andere, wo steht der Gag, naja, Chachibiti sagt jetzt völlig zu Recht unlustig, wie wäre es mit Schweizer Tüte, das verbindet Schweiz und Tüte auf eine nette und einfache Weise, oder vielleicht Schweizer Tütli als Anspielung auf die schweizerische Art. Aber finde ich brauchbarer, ehrlich gesagt, Schweizer Tütli finde ich brauchbarer als Tüte gegen Schweiz, wer hat mehr Löcher. Ich schreibe gerne lustiger. Es darf gerne noch 30% lustiger sein. Wie wäre es mit Schweizer Mischung oder noch lustiger Schweizer Tüte? Man könnte auch Tüttli-Schwitz oder Schweizer Sack sagen. Das bringt den schweizerischen Touch mit rein und klingt gleichzeitig unglaublich witzig. Aber Schweizer Sackli, also wollen Sie es? Schweizer Sackli, ja. Ja, das wäre doch perfekt. Ja, ja, ja. Doch, finde ich besser. Also, Chachibiti hat hier definitiv gewonnen. Okay, 1-0 für Chachibiti. Ich finde aber auch gut, dass Chachibiti sich verteidigt und sagt, ne, ich finde es saulustig. Ne, aber ich finde es sehr lustig. Also, ich finde es sehr lustig. Also, wir finden es hier, ich habe intern hier, also wir alle, Sie können alle fragen, alle Maschinen fragen. Vielleicht gibt es dann eine Diskrepanz zwischen Mensch und verschiedenen Humor, wir verstehen es, mega lustig. Ja, das kann sein, ja. Naja, also hat mich dann nochmal im Stich gelassen, aktuell ist unser Berufsstand noch nicht gefährdet. Entschuldige mich, ich habe schlimm Husten. Was ist los? Ich muss aber sagen, mir gefällt meine Stimme sehr gut. Mir gefällt es ja auch, muss ich jetzt sagen. Ich glaube, eine einfache Erkältung. Namentlich komme ich nicht mit dem Wetter zurecht gerade. Es scheint draussen die Sonne. Erzähl mir mehr, Stefan, erzähl mir mehr. Ich ziehe mir dann immer nur ein T-Shirt an, weil ich denke, die warme Sonne wird meine Haut berühren und sanft streichen. Und dann war es bitter, bitter kalt und ich sass bestimmt drei, vier Stunden in einem Café bei einem wichtigen Business-Meeting, aus dem man nicht raus konnte. Drei, vier Stunden? Drei Stunden bestimmt sass ich in der unfassbaren Kälte nur mit einem T-Shirt bekleidet. Von daher Audible, ihr habt jetzt ein ganz, ganz kleines Zeitfenster, in dem ich euch cool Bücher einsprechen kann, mit einer hotten, tiefen Stimme. Ja, jetzt nochmal die Handy-Nummer. Wir haben so zwei, drei Tage jetzt Zeit. Also wenn ihr mich fragt, weil er antwortet mir seit Jahren nicht, deswegen meine ich jetzt diese zwei, drei Wochen wären jetzt halt entscheidend. Renn am besten jetzt zu Audible und sag Leute, ich muss durch, lasst mich in die Tonkabine, ich muss durch, warte mal, Schumannstrasse 6 in Berlin ist Audible, in Berlin. Schumannstrasse? Schumannstrasse 6 in Berlin, da kannst du hin. Ich renne da kurz hin. Da kannst du schnell hin zu Audible. Aber jetzt, ja. Ich wollte ja tatsächlich mal, ich habe angefangen, ein Hörbuch einzusprechen. Und weil es gab eine Zeit lang, vielleicht gibt es immer noch LibriVox, eine Open Source Hörbuch Plattform, wo Hobby als Sprecher, Hobby Sprecher einfach Bücher einlesen konnten, die aus der Public Domain sind oder hoffentlich sein sollten.
Und dann konnte man die da hochladen. Ich dachte, das ist mein Durchbruch als Sprecher. Und ich war aber, glaube ich, so faul, dass ich nach zweieinhalb Seiten aufgegeben habe und das Ganze auch nie veröffentlicht habe. Du fragst dich wahrscheinlich, was habe ich eingelesen? Ja. Es war ein Science-Fiction-Roman namens Auf verlorenen Posten. Ich hatte mir damals nämlich, das war zu meiner Philosophie-Studiumszeit, habe ich mir nämlich zu Weihnachten einige Bücher gewünscht, die ich haben wollte, unter anderem von dem slowenischen Philosophen Slavoj Žižek Auf verlorenen Posten. Ein Buch über Politik und Philosophie und so, über den er schreibt. Meine Mutter hat diesen Buchwunsch dann erfüllt, allerdings den gleichnamigen Science-Fiction-Trash-Roman. Weil sie dir nicht zugetraut hat, Dzišek lesen zu wollen. Entweder war es ein versteckter Hinweis, wie sehr sie denkt, dass mein Philosophiestudium läuft, oder sie hat einfach das erstbeste Buch genommen, das so heisst. Wobei das erstbeste Buch mir hier, Slavar D mir hier slawin zizek angezeigt wird auf dem posten ja aber ich hatte dann auf jeden fall diesen trashigen science fiction roman und dachte mir was mache ich jetzt damit wäre doch witzig den einzulesen hast du ihn gelesen erst nein ich dachte ich war zu faul für alles weil das problem ist ja beim einlesen eigentlich musst du ja den kompletten roman durchgehen und dem markieren, welche Figur was sagt, wenn du Figuren leicht unterschiedlich reden willst, weil oft ist es ja so, Captain, Captain, wir müssen unbedingt abdrehen, die Gorgonen haben sich auf den Asteroiden im Asteroidengürtel gepflanzt, sagte Amy. Brigitte. So, und jetzt erst kommt die Figur. Ja, ja, genau. Und wenn du sagst, du willst Amy anders sprechen als Baymy, den Killerroboter. Ja, und jetzt bei Herr der Ringe zum Beispiel, wo dann, keine Ahnung, hinten rauskommt, dass es Gandalf war, der die Leute im Fangornwald oder wo auch immer das war begrüsst. Ja, das ist natürlich besonders schwierig, da musst du die Stimmen mischen. Nee, ich meine, aber du kannst da zumindest eine Mischform, du kannst was machen, aber du kannst es interpretieren, aber du musst es dafür gelesen haben. Du musst eigentlich den ganzen Roman kennen. Wenn er auf der letzten Seite rauskommt, dann musst du den ganzen Seite gut sprechen. Versteht ihr das immer? Oder das war der andere, von dem man dachte, er wäre schon tot in Verkleidung. Ja, hätte ich hier die ganze Zeit schon so sprechen können, dass man das raushören kann. Also super schwierig, ähm, riesen, riesen Respekt an Leute, die Hörbücher machen, es ist wahnsinnig viel Arbeit, viele, viele Stunden
fliessen da rein, dafür, dass man es
hört, während man schläft.
Genau, dafür, dass man es hört, während man schläft und dann am nächsten
Tag wieder anfängt, abends im Bett zum Einschlafen das
zu hören, anmacht,
auf Play drückt, merkt, das habe ich noch nie gehört,
das habe ich wieder noch nie gehört,
dann geht man 30 Sekunden zurück und denkt sich,
weiss ich nicht, dann drückt man noch mal ein paar Mal auf 30 Sekunden und merkt man, das kenne ich schon. Dann hört man es weiter und denkt, das kenne ich alles schon. Und bis man dann diesen Sweet Spot gefunden hat, wo man sagt, das ist der letzte Satz, den ich noch beim Bewusstsein abends gehört habe. Aber dann hat man zwei Sitz weiter und schlgt ein. Und so ist es so wirklich so vier Schritte nach vorne, acht zurück. Ja. Vier nach vorne, okay, ich habe die Stelle gefunden. Und dann geht es weiter, aber es ist schon anstrengend. Ich finde das ja auch spannend, diese, es gibt, die meisten Websites oder Player haben ja diesen Zurückknopf mittlerweile. Und auch Podcast-Apps oder so kannst du dann vor und zurück skippen. Du willst den Zurückklopf löschen? Nee, ich finde ganz spannend, für welche Sekundenzahl welche Player sich entschieden haben, weil es ist nicht einheitlich. Manche haben 30 Sekunden, manche 15, manche 10 und das ist wirklich... Manche haben ihn nicht, manche haben ihn nicht, genau. Dein Instinkt ist manchmal ein bisschen falsch, weil du denkst dir, ah, das will ich nochmal hören, bap bap bap, drei Knöpfe und du bist im Intro und denkst dir, wo bin ich jetzt so? Da hat sich die Branche noch nicht geeinigt. Rufst du ein Conceal aus? Rufst du das Conceal aus? Nee, ich bin da nicht für eine Normung. Du bist nicht für eine Normung? Ich bin nicht für eine Normung, ich bin für ein dynamisches System, wie wir es haben, weil Audible ist zu Recht bei 30 Sekunden. Weil es ja lang ist. Es ist ein langes Ding. Ich glaube, bei YouTube sind es zehn. Und da geht es ja auch, wenn du zurück willst, dann willst du nochmal das Kapitel. Es geht nicht um den Satz. Na, manchmal geht es um den Satz. Ja, ja. Naja, ich gebe dir schon recht, aber ich finde bei Audible eigentlich 30 Sekunden auch besser. Weil wenn ich beim Schlafen gehe, da geht es dann wirklich nicht um zehn Sekunden, die man verpasst hat, sondern um mal ganze Kapitel. Die Idee für Audible springt nicht eine fixe Sekundenzahl, sondern springt den Satz zurück.
Oder springt zwei Sätze, einen Satz anfang. Genau, das Kapitel, oder hat einen Satz zurück und ein Kapitel zurück, man kann sich entscheiden, wollte ganz zurück oder so.
Wie damals gab es ja diese, bei CD-Playern gab es Play, Stop, dann gab es zwei Pfeile, also ein Pfeil nach vorne, zwei Pfeile nach vorne, ein Pfeil zurück, zwei Pfeile zurück. Das eine war der ganze Song, das andere war Spulen.
Ja, ja. Spulen aber gibt's nicht mehr Spulen, ne? Spulen ist raus. Spulen ist raus. Spulen ist komplett raus. Skippen spulen das spulen ist raus spulen ist komplett raus skippen ist in spulen ist raus schade eigentlich spulen hatte eine gewisse magie ne vs-kassette und so ist alles gespult und heute nur noch skippen elektrospule hat schon sein ja ja das klingt schon ein bisschen veraltet ich möchte noch mal den bogen zurück zum anfang schliessen weil mich lässt nicht los wie sieht deine perfekte gemischte Tüte aus? Weil das ist spannend. Du hast, ich glaube, das war weniger eine altruistische Geste, als für dich herauszufinden ein Experiment. Was ist die perfekte gemischte Tüte? Also mein perfider Plan ist folgend, ich bin Unternehmer, ich bin jung Unternehmer und was natürlich wichtig ist, wenn du neues Unternehmen aufmachst, ist Marktforschung.
Marktforschung ist in der Regel teuer, deswegen habe ich mich nach Möglichkeiten umgesuhlt, zu sagen, wie kann ich kostenlose Marktforschung bekommen. Und da ist Rocket Beans TV an mich herangetreten. Beziehungsweise ich habe den Sender angeschaltet. Du bist da herangetreten. Ich habe den Sender angeschaltet. Du bist da herangesuhlt. Und dann habe ich gesehen, ah, die machen Public Viewing. Die Idee ist, dass man Fussball schaut, während man das im Second Screen noch die Nasen da sitzen sieht oder hört oder so. Welche Nasen? Etienne Gotti, Nils Bromhoff, Johanna von Rocket Beans TV, alle dabei. Und dann dachte ich mir, das ist ja ideale Marktforschung, weil ich lege die in die Tüten hin und kann die beobachten, wie die essen, was die essen, ob die sich freuen. Normalerweise gucken Fussball, Florentin guckt mit noch angespannten, grossen Augen auf die Leute, die Fussball gucken, während sie seine gemischten Tüten essen. Und macht sie den Notizen an so ein Klemmbrett. Hast du einen weissen Kittel an? Du kannst ja danach sagen, ja, ich fand die Tüte gut, aber ich sag nein, dein Gesicht hat was anderes gesagt, als du die sauren Würmchen gegessen hast.
Ja, das war, weil Deutschland eins nur hinten liegt. Ja, na gut, aber kann auch in den Reese's Pieces liegen. So, und da... Ja, die brauche ich nicht in der Tüte. Aha, so, und da gucke ich natürlich genau hin, weil langfristig soll daraus natürlich schon ein Unternehmen werden. Was für ein Unternehmen? Weil ich würde natürlich gerne die verkaufen und da habe ich tatsächlich, Mensch ist ja hier passend, habe ich auch wieder direkt KI hinzugezogen, jetzt habe ich es geschlossen. Aber wir haben doch mal über gemischte Tüte und Com gesprochen. Weil ich habe mich nämlich gefragt und ganz kurz, falls jemand zuhört, Christian Solmecke, Rechtsanwalt und Partner bei WBS Legal in Köln, Falls Sie zuhören, wie läuft das denn, wenn ich jetzt, sagen wir mal, Haribo und Cola-Flaschen und Skittles und M&Ms kaufe, die mische und dann weiterverkaufe, zum Beispiel auf Amazon, Floris Tüte, wenn ich die verkaufe auf Amazon, ist das erlaubt oder darf man nur Sachen verkaufen, die man auch selber hergestellt hat? Weil letzten Endes kann ja Ernestel sagen oder wer auch immer Mondeley kann sagen,
das ist einfach unser Zeug, das darf man nicht. Du darfst das nicht kommerziell verkaufen. Inwiefern musst du das Produkt verändern, um es weiter zu verkaufen oder die Einzelteile? Ja, genau. Also ich habe ja vor langer, langer Zeit mal die Frage gestellt, was ist, wenn ich eine Flasche Pepsi kaufe, eine Flasche Coca-Cola kaufe, die mische und das verkaufe als Florentins Supercola. Ja, aber jetzt genau, super spannend. Also wie sehr müssen die Einzelteile zur Summe werden? Also angenommen, weil du kannst ja auch Mehl kaufen. Ist das wirklich die spannende Frage? Pass auf, nein, es ist nicht die spannende Frage, es ist zugegeben, noch nicht die spannende Frage, aber du kannst, aber du kaufst dir Mehl. Das ist eine Frage, aber ist es okay, ist es nicht okay? Nee, aber Florian, du kannst doch Mehl kaufen im Supermarkt. Ja. Jetzt könnte man als Mehlfirma, kannst du ja Bäcker verklagen und sagen, ihr benutzt unser Mehl. Ja, ja, ja. Ich verstehe schon, die Schöpfung zu hören. Ihr kauft uns unser Mehl ab, habt ihr einen kompletten Vollschaden. Hä? Der ist für den privaten Gebrauch und nie war die Idee daraus, Kuchen zu machen. Nein, nie. Wir denken klein für den Bürger. Und für den schönen Löffel Mehl am Morgen. Aber du lachst bei deiner Frage, Christian Solmecke, hörst du zu? Christian Solmecke hat nämlich auf eine andere Frage von uns geantwortet. Richtig, der Rechtsweg. Nämlich, wir haben die Frage gestellt, was genau bedeutet die Klausel, der Rechtsweg ist ausgeschlossen. Kann ich jemanden ermorden und während ich das Messer in die Halsschlagader ramme sagen, der Rechtsweg ist ausgeschlossen, sodass der Anwalt, der neben mir steht, sagt, ah, nein, verdammt, nicht noch eins, er hat mich erwischt und dann kann ich keine Strafe kriegen. Mir von uns ja, Christian Sommer hat nämlich geet, und das hat er gesagt. Ich halte es ganz nah dran. Hör auf, so zu gucken, ich kriege das hin. Wahrscheinlich der am wenigsten verstandene Satz der Geschichte ist ja der Rechtsweg ist ausgeschlossen. Klinge ich immer noch so nasal eigentlich? War, habe ich da irgendwie Erdnisflips in der Nase steckig raus gerade? Ist nicht alles, hä, aber wir können es dem Rechtsweg ja nicht ausschliessen. Ja, das ist tatsächlich eine gute Frage. Die Klausel Der Rechtsweg ist ausgeschlossen. Die ist für einen Vertrag nur dann wirksam, wenn zwischen den Parteien kein Ungleichgewicht besteht. Das ist zwischen Verbrauchern und Unternehmern eigentlich nie der Fall, denn der Unternehmer, der gilt immer als die wirtschaftlich stärkere Partei und kann so eine Klausel ja auch potenziell ausnutzen. Die einzige Ausnahme sind einige Gewinnspiele. Wenn da ein Teilnehmer nichts verlieren, sondern mit Glück nur gewinnen kann, dann hat er gar kein Risiko und diese besondere Machtposition, die besteht dann nicht. Deshalb sagt zumindest das Landgericht Hannover, in solchen Fällen darf sich der Unternehmer mit der Formulierung Der Rechtsweg ist ausgeschlossen vor Klage führen. Dann haben wir ja gar keine Frage. Vielen Dank. Vielen Dank. Ey, wir haben das ja aus Spaß gesagt. Ja, ja, das ist ja nie ernst. Warum bist du da so chill? Ich finde das bei mir ja stolz drauf. Total, ja, total. Ich finde es richtig cool. Vielen Dank. Ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden, aber ich habe es so ein bisschen verstanden. Ich habe es auch ein bisschen verstanden, ja. Aber nicht ganz verstanden. Aber aktuell ist der, wir haben den Rechtsweger wieder aktiviert. Wir haben den ja für eine kurze Zeit mal ausgeschlossen, dann haben wir ihn wieder aktiviert. Also er ist gerade aktiv. Sollen wir ihn vorsichtshalber doch wieder ausschliessen oder bleiben wir jetzt dabei? Wir bleiben mal bei der Linie jetzt. Gut, wir bleiben mal das ja. Ich habe nachzulassen. Das ist eine sehr gute Frage, nicht mehr zugehört. Ich habe nur noch gehört. Ja, das ist wirklich, das ist wirklich eine sehr gute, das ist wirklich, sehr, sehr gute. Da ist ja als Podcast eine tolle Frage entstanden. Ja, das ist genau wie in der Schule, wo man, wo man dann irgendwann hört, ja, wenn du eine gute mündliche Note haben willst, dann musst du Fragen stellen im Unterricht und irgendwann dann so, ja, aber, also wie war das denn, wie war denn die Beziehung zwischen Caligula und Caesar dann letztlich? Und dann fängt der Lehrer an zu antworten und man hört einfach nicht zu, ist einem völlig egal. Man sagt, ich habe eine Frage gestellt. Man macht nicht so einen Strich auf den... Ich habe eine Frage gestellt. Boah, ich fand das immer so weird, wenn Lehrer so Strichlisten gemacht haben, wenn man sich gemeldet hat. Für die mitteilliche Note. Wie unbeteiligt kann man sein, wie entkoppelt von einer Klasse und wie scheissegal kann man der Job sein, wenn man sich … Ja, aber du möchtest Objektivität warten, auch Lehrer hassen manche Schüler und dann werden die Meldungen nicht angerechnet. Aber es geht doch wirklich nicht um die Anzahl der Wortmeldungen. Das ist auch eine Art von Fairness, ist eine Art von Fairness. Was du nämlich dann damit heranziehst, ist eine Gesellschaft, wo im Zoom-Meeting, obwohl alles geklärt ist, immer noch Leute sagen, ja gut, ich will noch einmal, das ist halt, alle wollen immer was sagen, des Sagens wegen, nicht um fucking Inhalt zu transportieren. Du kannst ja gute, ich finde, man kann gute mündliche Noten verteilen an Leute, die nicht wahnsinnig viel netto Wörter gesagt haben. Und da kommen wir wieder zu unserem Motto, nichts ist besser als was. Keine Frage ist besser als eine schlechte Frage. Und du möchtest also, ja, du möchtest also das Schulsystem revolutionieren, indem du sagst, Meldungen ohne Inhalt sollen nicht gutiert werden. Meldungen ohne Inhalt sollen nicht gutiert werden. Ja. Ja, ich habe nach meiner tollen Idee jetzt nicht mehr zugehört. Aber finde ich spannend, finde ich spannend. Diesen Zwang, zumindest einmal was gesagt zu haben, sich einmal zu melden, kommt das tatsächlich aus der Schule? Diese Strichliste, das ist wirklich das albernste. Ich finde, das ist super faul als Lehrer, so eine Strichliste zu machen. Ich meine, klar, du willst am Ende des Tages die Diskussion haben, so ja, warum kriege ich nur nur drei mündlich, ich habe doch mehr gesagt, ich will mindestens zwei, Petra hat auch nur zwei bekommen und dann stehst du in diesem merkwürdigen Rechtfertigungszwang, aber dann own it, du bist ja Lehrer. Du bist ja Diktator. Du hast ja nicht ausgewürfelt, sondern du hast ja wahrscheinlich dir Gedanken gemacht, dann own it und dann respektiere deine Entscheidung und dann mach das. Keine Strichliste. Okay. Strichliste, danke. Ich habe das auch Claude gefragt, der meinte, es ist erlaubt, Süßigkeiten zu kaufen und dann in gemischten Tüten weiter zu verkaufen. Allerdings gibt es wichtige Einschränkungen. Egal, aber es ist generell erlaubt und deswegen war das natürlich die Idee, wie ich langfristig natürlich die gemischte Tüte revolutionieren kann. Problem ist, man muss natürlich angeben, was drinnen ist, was natürlich die Überraschungseffekt,
für den ich viel Geld verlange,
ein wenig zuwiderläuft, aber
ich glaube, es ist eine gute Idee.
Die gemischte Tüte braucht einen neuen Anstrich.
Okay, jetzt möchte ich wissen, wie bist du rangegangen?
Es erinnert mich übrigens an die Larry David
Curb Your Enthusiasm Folge, wo er
die Minibar revolutionieren will,
indem er die Minibar neu zusammenstellt,
wo ich auch finde, da liegt wahnsinnig Potenzial. Total. Ich fand auch im Hotel, die hatten eine ganz tolle Minibar mit tollen Chips und ich finde immer das süss-salzig-Verhältnis muss stimmen, da liegt viel. Ich brauche nicht immer diese wahnsinnig experimentellen Dinge, ich mag auch manchmal einfach eine Pringles-Dose, die finde ich gut, da weiß ich, was ich bekomme. Ich mag keine Überraschungen. Man hat diese Tüten, dann hat man nichts mehr gegessen abends, reisst irgendwas aus der Minibar auf, denkt, das ist einfach irgendwie Schokobällchen oder sowas, und dann hast du da drin irgendwie noch so, weiss ich nicht, Rum oder irgendwie sowas Spezielles oder Pistaziencreme mit Tonka. Also das ist dann, dann denke ich mir, nein, nein, nein. Also es gibt verschiedene Achsen für mich. Es gibt erstmal ganz klar die Achse klein, gross. Wie viel Dimension reden wir? Von drei, vielleicht sogar ein vierdimensionaler Würfel auf jeden Fall. Vielleicht gehen wir in die fünfte Dimension, wenn es gut läuft. Ich will kleine Sachen in der Tüte, ich will grosse Sachen in der Tüte. Ich mag es, wenn unten in der Tüte noch kleine Sachen sind, die man dann noch so rausfummeln kann und so kleine Sachen. Deswegen mag ich kleine Tropifrutti und habe ich extra auf Amazon bestellt kleine Colorado, Colorado Mini. Die gibt's nämlich noch mal in kleinerer Variante, diese Colorado-Misch. Warum ist es so toll, du willst was zu fummeln haben, du willst Textur. Ich will was zu fummeln haben, unten dann noch so ein bisschen die Giebig, weil meine Erfahrung ist oft, die Giebig ist zu schnell leer und dann will ich am Ende noch so ein bisschen, gerade wenn man noch was schaut, noch was fummeln oder so, noch kleine Sachen rausholen, ah, noch mal ein kleines, so ein bisschen kleine Sachen. Oder man kippt's, man kippt's natürlich und alles rein. Und dann macht man diesen Vater-Move, wo man dann so die Hand so schüttelt und dann, was macht der da genau mit? Und dann wird der Kopf in den Nacken geworfen. Es gibt gewisse Dinge, die müssen immer in Bewegung bleiben. Würfel zum Beispiel. Sobald die vom Tisch genommen werden, müssen die durchgehend in Bewegung bleiben. Die dürfen nie ruhen. Und Nüsschen. Wenn man Nüsschen so raus will aus so einer Schüssel, dann muss die Hand so gerüttelt werden, als wenn man so eine Rüttelmaschine. Und dann wird der Kopf in den Nacken geworfen und dann wird sich die Nüsse eingeworfen. Effizient. Und ich habe es noch nicht mal aus Spaß gemacht, es macht wahnsinnig viel Spaß, so Nüsse zu essen. Super, total gut. Okay, super. Also ich will die Achse klein gross, ich will die Achse hart weich. Ich will Sachen haben, die wirklich gross sind, wo ich mich ranbeissen kann, ich will Sachen, die ich wirklich gut wegsnacken kann, ich will Sachen, die man ein bisschen kauen muss. Die optische Ebene spielt für dich eine Rolle, weil du ja die ja nicht siehst. Keine Rolle. Ja. Dann will ich saure Sachen. Das Problem bei sauren Sachen ist oft, dass sie zu stark kontaminieren. Also, na ja, die Frage ist, also es gibt, das Wort Mischung hat zwei Bedeutungen in meinem Kopf. Die erste Bedeutung ist sowas wie eine Apfelsaftschorle, das ist eine Mischung. Immer wenn du trinkst, kriegst du beide Komponenten. Döner, wenn du reinbeisst, kriegst du alle Komponenten, Salat ist eine Mischung. Aber die gemischte Tüte ist das ja nicht, weil du isst die Teile ja einzeln. Es ist also eher ein Sortiment, es ist nicht ein Salat, es ist ein Sortiment. Die Frage ist jetzt, wie sehr dürfen die einzelnen Objekte die anderen beeinflussen? Ja, eigentlich nicht. So, aber das ist die Frage, ist nicht die Schönheit einer gemischten Tüte auch, dass wenn du da jetzt so saure Pommes drin hast, dass die auch die anderen Sachen ein bisschen anzuckern? Nein, willst du das oder willst du das nicht? Und das ist eine Glaubensfrage. Die Dinge für sich sind perfekt. Das ist eine Glaubensfrage, weil dann musst du nämlich, wenn du konsequent... Schichtensystem. Wenn du auf deiner Linie konsequent bist, darfst du gar keine saure Pommes reinnehmen. Doch, und zwar ganz unten. Na, aber die bleibt nicht ganz unten. Die Leute mischen das. Aber dann kannst du dich aus der Verantwortung ziehen, als gemischte Tüte.org. Was ich gemacht habe, ich habe, als ich diese saure Britzeldinger gemacht habe, ich habe die in Sieb getan und abgeschüttelt. Das hast du nicht vorher gemacht. Habe ich gemacht, ich habe die abgeschüttelt. Das hast du nicht vorher gemacht. Doch, doch, damit wirklich die losen Zuckersachen runter sind und die relativ fest sind. Wir kennen seit mehr als zehn Jahren jetzt. Du hast dir noch für nichts, was wir jemals gemacht haben, so viel Mühe gegeben, wie für diese gemischte Tüte. Ja, ich dachte... Wir sind Urlaube gefahren, haben gebucht, waren unterwegs gemeinsam, haben Touren gespielt, haben viele Projekte gemeinsam gemacht. Und ich kenne dich als jemand, der genau weiss, was er will, du weisst, wie du eine Freizeit gestaltest. Und ich finde es super, aber dass du so viel Mühe dir gibst, dass du das kannst, ist mir neu und verletzt mich rückblickend. Weil du dir denkst, warum hat er sich für mich nie Mühe gegeben. Aber dann wiederum, ich verstehe schon, du verfolgst deinen eigenen Plan auch ein bisschen. Es ist mein eigenes Unternehmen, es ist meine Firma und da muss ich ran. Und deswegen dachte ich, so kriege ich Best of Both Worlds, gehe ich rein. Aber dann gibt es noch eine ganz interessante Achse, nämlich bekannt und neu. Für mich ist eine gemischte Tüte Nostalgie, da will ich zu Hause sein, da will ich einen Kracher, da will ich den Schlumpf, da will ich den Schnuller. Aber du willst auch Überraschungen. Genau, weil die gemischte Tüte ist einer der wenigen Orte, wo man neue Dinge ausprobieren kann. Die Süßigkeitenindustrie hat unglaubliche Innovationskraft, die oft verschmäht wird. Ein Beispiel. Das glaube ich nämlich, da muss ich dir hart übersprechen, weil die Lidls, Aldis, Edeka und Revis da draußen bieten seit 20, 30 Jahren die gleichen Sachen an. Das ist nicht richtig. Pass auf. Ahoy Brause. Kennen wir alle. Ja. Weisst du, was eines deren Produkte war? Ahoy Brause Waffeln. Wie Mannerwaffeln, nur mit Ahoy Brause Schichten., und das Produkt wurde verschmäht, weil es einfach zu innovativ, zu neu, zu verrückt war. Und da sage ich, da braucht es Leute wie mich, die sagen, du greifst zur Tüte, ich schmuggel dir diese Innovationsdinge unter, damit du sie mal siehst. Damit du mal so eine Ahoi-Brause-Waffel, die gibt es glaube ich mittlerweile nicht mehr, war nicht sehr beliebt, kam nicht gut an, weil niemand wusste, was soll das sein, weil die Leute wollen entweder eine Mannerwaffel haben oder Ahoy-Brause, aber es gibt keinen Raum in deren Kopf für Waffeln, die sauer und britzlig sind, so das gibt's und deswegen denke ich, sowas braucht's. Also indem es genau gegenteilig war, klar gibt es ab und zu mal solche Dinge, die sind dann aber sehr schnell wieder aus dem Sortiment oder so. Ich erinnere mich auch mal an so Bonbons von Ahoy Brause, aber die habe ich auch nicht mehr gesehen. Jetzt hast du wieder diese Tüten überall stehen. Und Deutschland ist meiner Meinung nach einfach seit 20, 30 Jahren stehen geblieben mit der Lüssigkeitenindustrie. Da guckst du nicht genau hin. Ja, ja, aber du redest von Ausnahmen, du redest nicht von Dingen, die jetzt neu. Sag mal ein Produkt, was in den letzten fünf Jahren entstanden ist und vom Markt aufgegriffen wurde, insoweit, als dass es jetzt überall in jedem Laden steht. Oreos. In den letzten fünf Jahren. Die sind schon älter, ne? Aber die kamen auch irgendwann. Und in den USA, wenn du da, deswegen freuen wir uns ja immer so, wenn wir in den USA sind, weil da ja wirklich wöchentlich neue Produkte entstehen, wahnsinnig viel Innovationskraft da drin ist, wahnsinnig viele Dinge miteinander gemischt werden. Und Deutschland ist immer so, jetzt kommen langsam mal diese ganzen Rieses-Sachen so nach Deutschland. Rieses-Pieses kommen jetzt, ja. Ja, aber das meine ich ja gar nicht. Ich meine, so was, was ist entstanden aus den Produkten, die wir haben, von den Marken, die wir kennen in den letzten paar Jahren? Also Innovationswüste, Süssigkeiten, Innovationswüste, Deutschland. Aber du gibst denen auch keine Chance. Ich gebe denen auch keine Chance. Ich gebe denen Chance. Du hast immer die Amicellis, die Giotos, die erste da stehen. Wie kannst du in jeder Folge Amicelli und Giotto? Es fällt erstaunlich einfach. Amicelli und Giotto gehören auch irgendwie zusammen. Ich mag beide gerne. Das sind Brüder, das sind irgendwie Brüder, die nicht wissen, dass sie dieselben Eltern teilen. Ich sag dir jetzt mal meine Lieblingssüßigkeiten und du sagst, was ist das verbindende Element und das ist sehr einfach. Meine Lieblingssüßigkeiten sind Amicelli, Giotto, Kinder Bueno, I Love Milka, diese Herzen, diese Herzenpackung von Milka, diese Herzen.
Ach so.
Die Nuss-Nougat-Haselnuss-Pralines, ja sowas.
Ja, Nuss.
Ja, Haselnuss. Aber ich mag Haselnüsse gar nicht so gerne als Nuss.
Nicht die Erdnuss? Erdnuss-Haselnuss?
Erdnuss mag ich gerne, Haselnuss mag ich gar nicht als Nuss, aber alle meine Sachen, die ich so als Süssigkeiten mag, die süssen Sachen, verbindet alle das Element Haselnusscreme.
Fantastisch, als Creme fantastisch, als Nuss unerträglich. Ja, nee, es ist ein schmaler Grad. Ich habe ja sogar bei der ersten Generation der Tüten Schokobons in die Tüte getan. Die habe ich ausgepackt und reingetan in die Tüte und Leute haben überhaupt nicht damit gerechnet. Die dachten, was ist das Schokoeier oder so und plötzlich Schokobon, weil du denkst nie an die als nackt. Aber das ist mir hier schon übergrifflich, die auszupacken und dann nackt ein Blödsinn reinzuschmeissen. Es hat sich auch nicht gut angefühlt. Um ganz ehrlich zu sein, es hat sich nicht gut angefühlt, da wirklich so eine Gruppe Schokobons zu entkleiden. Und die lagen dann in so einer Schüssel, nackt und frierend und ängstlich und zitternd und dachten, was passiert mit uns? Die sind auch angreifbar. Die sind richtig angreifbar. Weil wenn da so eine Pommes, so eine saure Pommes gegenstößt, da kommt doch das Weiss schon so raus. Das Blut des Schokobongs. Ja, ja, die waren richtig verunsichert. Würde ich auch nicht nochmal machen, weil das einfach, das tut weh. Ich finde, das ist eins vor, du nimmst ein Kinderbueno und brichst es ab und machst das dann da rein. Es gibt ja die einzelnen Kapseln auch zu kaufen, aber die zu zerbrechen, das ist schon hart. Daraus sind schreien Kinder. Ja, zu Recht. Völlig zu Recht. Super. Ich begleite das sehr, sehr gerne. Ich habe da richtig viel Spaß dran. Und ich glaube, du hast eine sehr, sehr gute Idee davon, wie du es machst. Ich mag diesen Gegensatz, diese Grafen sehr, weil ich glaube, so funktioniert ja auch Sterneküche. Es geht ja immer darum, möglichst das ganze Spektrum abzubilden. Der Geschmack, Geschmäcker, süss, salzig, sauer, bitter, Umami, das wäre auch noch spannend, so Beef Jerky machst du noch so rein.
Das ist jetzt natürlich die grosse Herausforderung, wie kriegst du Salziges rein, weil Salziges tendiert sehr zum Kontaminieren, wir denken an Nicknacks, wir denken an Chips, wir denken an Pommes, die würden halt einfach die komplette Tüte ruinieren. Jetzt habe ich überlegt, kann man so diese kleinen Fischlis reintun, aber die sind auch ein bisschen schal, die haben nicht so richtig Geschmack. Ich überlege noch, Salzstangen, zerbrochene, zerschmetterte Salzstangen, aber das ist dann alles salzig. Schwierig. Willst du wirklich ein Tropifrutti mit einem Stück Salz dran? Wahrscheinlich eher nicht. Boah, diese Kontaminations- ist ein Riesenproblem. Ist ein Riesenproblem.
Aber ich werde das fortführen und
vielleicht eines Tages, floristüte.de
kriegt ihr vielleicht auch eine für
einen horrenden Preis.
Ja, bis dahin schaut mal vorbei auf
gemischte-tüte.com, die machen genau das gleiche
und da könnt ihr euch die zusammenstellen.
Ebenfalls,
ihr wollt sie ja vielleicht euch gerade
nicht zu. Schaut mal vorbei auf gemischte-tüte.com, die machen genau das gleiche und da könnt ihr euch die zusammenstellen.
Falls ihr euch vielleicht gerade nicht zusammenstellen, sondern von einem intelligent Designer von nein, vielleicht soll jemand ein Manager, ein Tütenmanager, vielleicht, der sich besser auskennt, als tun sie das schon seit 2012. Ja, nee, finde ich es super. Es passiert auch einiges im Puddingbereich, also muss ich auch kurz nochmal sagen. Landliebe Pudding, es gab über lange Schokopudding, Vanillepudding, mittlerweile wird es mehr und mehr verdrängt durch Grießpudding, dass es nicht mehr Vanille gibt, sondern Grießwanille und jetzt auch gesehen Grießschokopudding von Landliebe.
Weiss ich nicht, ob ich das gut finde, was das für Hintergründe hat, ob man versucht, Gries jetzt weiter in den Markt zu drücken, woher das kommt, weil eigentlich der normale Schokopudding gibt es immer weniger. hast einerseits die danni sahne fraktion wo noch sahne umdrauf ist und jetzt so ein bisschen die kris aber dieser wirklich einfach schokopudding im becher gibt es immer weniger muss ich wirklich besorgt feststellen gegenwahrtsphänomen worauf führst du das zurück sind wir im gegenwahrtscheck anscheinend sind wir im Gegenwarts-Check, um den Punkt geben zu können.
Ich bin kein Pudding-Esser, mir ist es nicht aufgefallen. Ich würde sagen, dass unsere heutige Gesellschaft zum Anti-Hedonismus neigt. Alles, was wirklich ungesund ist, das wird hinterfragt. Es muss alles bio sein, es muss alles mit Chias haben, es muss alles irgendwie gesund und natürlich sein. Und da hat natürlich der klassische Schokopudding von Oma keinen Platz mehr, der wirklich für reinen Genuss, reine Gaumenfreude steht, sondern da muss dann nochmal irgendwie mit vegan oder nochmal irgendwelche Einschränkungen. Und du meinst sozusagen mit dem Behilfsmittel des Gris? Genau. Das Gris wird instrumentalisiert als gesunder Subsidiert. Genau, als gutes Gewissen beigemischt, dass man sagt, ah, das ist ja Grieß, das ist was Natürliches, das ist nicht einfach mit Zucker. Und da will man nämlich eigentlich doch die Schokolade haben. Genau, es ist immer eine Mischung, alles ist ein Kompromiss heutzutage. Ja, den Punkt kriegst du. Aber auch weil ich es nicht weiss, ich habe das Phänomen nicht beobachtet. Ich habe ein anderes Phänomen. Aber ich könnte über diesen Gegenwartscheck des Podcasts, die sogenannte Gegenwart viel reden, weil es, ich reg mich teilweise, ich reg mich so doll auf, ich reg mich so doll auf, ich reg mich so auf, also die Rubrik ist, man muss was Gegenwärtiges mitbringen und dann aber auch erklären, warum es gegenwärtig ist, was oft nicht getan wird, sondern einfach nur, ich hab was Neues gesehen und dann müssen die anderen Moderatoren Punkte verteilen. Und es ist einfach nur ein witziges, wir reden über Dinge, Ding. Aber ich nehme das zu ernst. Und ich bin teilweise beim Spazierengehen wirklich, ich habe letztens gegen Strassenscheet getreten. Ja, bei welchem Gegenwartspunkt? Weil es mich so geärgert hat. Ich nämlich, ich habe in der Bahn, ich habe in der Bahn so gemacht. Es ist so dumm, aber es macht mich lächerlich wütend. Ich weiss nicht, ob das ein Gegenwartsphänomen ist, dass es mich so wütend macht, wenn Leute da nicht konsequent ihr eigenes Format verstehen. Das ärgert mich so. Nee, die verstehen das schon. Manchmal ist es einfach... Die verstehen das nicht. Ich finde, Verständnis ist nicht das Problem. Es ist eher die Frage, ob man da eine gute Begründung immer findet oder ob man die Beobachtung so schön findet, dass man einfach das sagt. Aber ich rede mich da genauso drüber auf. Ich habe ein Gegenwartsphänomen, möchte ich auch mal an der Stelle. Okay. Also einzeln finde ich. Ja, und Lars Weisbrot hört gerade zu und tritt in der Tram gegen seinen Vordermann. Nee, weil das passt nämlich ganz gut dazu, weil mein Gegenwartsphänomen, das ich beobachtet habe, ist Podcasts, die das Thema nicht hinlänglich besprechen können, weil die Zeit aus ist. Dann sagen sie nämlich immer, ah, jetzt haben wir gar keine Zeit mehr. Und das ist so spannend, weil meine Lieblingspodcasts sind eigentlich gerade Servus, Grüezi, Hallo und die sogenannte Gegenwart und halt andere Podcasts, die von Leuten sind, die entweder festangestellt sind oder Freiberufler für die Firmen, für die sie die Podcasts machen, wie Zeit oder Spiegel oder so. Und die machen das halt auf so einer Payroll und haben dann nur eine Stunde Zeit. Aber das ist ja ganz, ganz diametral gegenüber, die Idee des Podcasts ist ja eben nicht, dass es linear ist und wir nur eine Stunde Zeit haben und dann kommt das nächste, sondern wir können ja, wer weiß, wie viele ins Internet senden, unbegrenzt.
aber weil jetzt weil es in so einem job weil die guten podcast die ich höre die meines
erachtens gut recherchiert sind oder sich mühe geben und gedanken machen sind von leuten bei
denen das so sehr ein job geworden ist dass es wieder linear wird und dann haben die eine stunde
zeit und dann machen die nämlich diesen gegenwartscheck immer, überziehen damit gottlos, weil die sich dann in die Haare bekommen, dann reden sie 20 Minuten über das Thema, kommen, kratzen so mir an der Oberfläche und dann machen sie noch, am Ende stellen sie dann die Zukunftsprognosefrage und dann sagen sie, ah, jetzt ist die Zeit schon rum und man denkt, ah, das kriegen wir jetzt nicht mehr hin, das reichen wir nach. Es wird ja nie nachgereicht. Nie. Weil dann die nächste, das ist ja, dafür ist es ja dann wieder zu sehr dann auch Podcast und ein fliessendes Bauchmedium, wo nicht dann irgendwie Dinge nachgehalten werden. Bauchmedium? Ja, so ein Bauch, aus dem Bauch raus Medium. Ach so, okay, das ist eine schöne Beobachtung, aber es fehlt jetzt noch, warum ist das gegenwärtig? Ja, gegenwärtig ist, weil die gut recherchierten, guten Podcasts inzwischen ausschliesslich von Leuten gemacht werden, dessen Job das ist. Weil grosse Zeitungen oder Verläge oder sowas, die machen die Podcasts, die es für mich wert sind zu hören, bei denen ist es aber halt ein Job und es ist nicht, wie das
Podcast-Medium eigentlich entstanden ist
oder benutzt wird von
Leuten wie uns, die aus Spaß
an erfreut, bis
unendlich viel Zeit
vergangen ist, in den Internet belabern.
Ich weiß nicht, ob mir das gegenwärtig
gelingt ist, ehrlich gesagt. Also du sagst,
die Professionalisierung des Internets führt
dazu, dass die eigentlichen Vorteile des Internets gar nicht genutzt werden.
Exakt. Das Internet fällt wieder in alte Muster zurück, weil jetzt machen nämlich Radiosender und Zeitungen mit begrenzt Platz, Medien, die mal begrenzt Platz hatten, machen Podcasts, wo sie unendlich viel Zeit hätten und benutzen das genauso wie damals. Es ist nicht so, ich gebe dir völlig recht, es ist nicht so, mir ist es nur aufgefallen, es ist nicht so wahnsinnig gegenwärtig.
Ja, aber das hatten wir in den Zehnerjahren schon, wo YouTuber angefangen haben, Serien zu machen und so und also dass die sich dem linearen Medien wieder annähern und sowas. Nee, YouTuber haben weniger, damals war auch die Zeit, die bei YouTube, die Upload-Time war begrenzt, auf zehn Minuten. Ja, das stimmt, ja. Nee, finde ich gut, aber ich glaube oft, dass es auch so ein Verlegenheitsding ist, wir haben nicht genug Zeit, weil die nehmen sich ja teilweise auch auf Themen vor, die riesengroß sind. Sie haben nichts mehr. Und ich glaube, es ist auch so eine gewisse Selbstentlastung zu sagen, ah, jetzt haben wir leider keine Zeit mehr, jetzt müssen wir es leider liegen lassen. Also wenn du das Thema anreißt, weißt du schon, wir werden es nicht beenden und dann geht man da auch locker rein, glaube ich, dass du einfach weißt, wir müssen kein richtiges Fazit finden, wir müssen nichts lösen, sondern man geht einfach mal rein.
Bei beiden Podcasts stört mich, dass sie nicht ins Detail gehen. Da hat man mal Leute, die so eine intellektuelle Kapazität haben, um diese Themen mir zu erklären und beizubringen, und es macht Spaß und sind charismatisch. Und dann kratzen sie an der Oberfläche und dann ist die Zeit vorbei. Und denkt sich, welche Zeit? Ich höre euch. Ich habe drei Podcasts, ihr könnt machen, was ihr wollt, aber die machen es halt nicht, weil sie dafür bezahlt werden, einmal die Woche eine Stunde Podcast zu machen. Das eine ist natürlich der Gegensatz, ist ja dieser Reaction-Content, wo du so aus einem 30-Minuten-Statement ein zwei Stunden Reaction-Video machst und dann macht der andere wieder ein vier Stunden Reaction-Video. und es bläst sich immer weiter auf und es wird immer mehr ins Detail, es geht immer, jeder Satz wird immer weiter erklärt und dann muss der, der dann den Satz gesagt hat, dann wieder erklären, warum man das anders meint. Ja, aber da habe ich ja wieder Spaß dran, weil Details machen ja Spaß. Ja, und dann wird es lustig, weil die Aufblähung von kleinen Details habe ich ja richtig viel Spaß dran. Ja, total. Sehr schön, gut, um uns geht uns geht jetzt auch seine... Okay, also eins zu eins im Gegenwarts-Check.
Können wir gerne häufiger machen, was wir trägt.
Finde ich auch lustig, ja.
Aber wir müssen es begründen, da gebe ich dir recht.
Nicht einfach nur, das sehe ich jetzt gerade überall so, das ärgert mich immer.
Aber bei uns ist auch die Zeit um.
Ja, richtig, wir haben leider keine Zeit mehr.
Ah, wir hatten jetzt eigentlich noch ein paar richtig gute Hörereinsendungen.
Gut, dann reichen wir erst nach, machen wir nicht.
Aber das verlinken wir dann. In den Shownotes. Das ist die grösste Lüge. Niemals aus einem Ansatz versucht, den Link rauszusuchen. Völlig richtig. Sind Links nicht mehr zeitgemäß? Links? Ja. Ja, QR-Codes kann man ja schon oder so abscannen Dinge oder so. Ja, Links braucht auch niemand mehr. Ich schicke dir einen Link. Verschickst du mehr Links als noch letztes Jahr oder weniger? Ja, Videos teilen ist ja auch streng genommen, Links schicken, ne? Also hier sind TikTok-Teile oder ein YouTube-Video. Machst du das denn noch? Ich bin da müde geworden so ein bisschen, muss ich sagen. Teilen müde geworden? Ich bin richtig te bin richtig teilgern. Ich teile gerne, ich sage richtig viel gern. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass jeder alles kennt so, dass sich die Algorithmen zu sehr annähern. Weil eigentlich machen die Algorithmen das ja automatisch, Sachen zu teilen. Wenn du was gut findest, kriegen deine Freunde das automatisch auch vorgeschlagen. Und dann musst du es ja gar nicht mehr teilen. Ich denke mir so, wenn ich was like, denke ich mir, der Algorithmus sorgt dafür, dass die Leute, mit denen ich auf Instagram folge und die mir folgen, dass die das eh sehen und dann muss ich denen das auch nicht mehr schicken. Weil dann schicke ich denen das und dann sagt die, ja, das habe ich ja schon gesehen. Ja, das kommt häufig, das ist das Schlimmste, wenn du dich freust über ein lustiges Video, was du gefunden hast, dann schickst du es jemandem und dann kommst zurück. Das kann ich schon. Das kann mich den Tag ruinieren. Aber ja, die Algorithmen gauken einem eigentlich vor, finde ich, dass man einen sehr, sehr individuellen, coolen Feed hat. Ja, ja, das ist ja, habe ich letztens auch gesehen, so dieser Zwang zu erwähnen, dass man schon was kennt. Da wurde ein tolles Video im Reddit vorgeschlagen, ich erinnere mich leider nicht mehr ganz genau, was, na doch, da ging es um Two and a Half Men, um das obskure Ende von Two and a Half Men. Ich habe ja nie Two and a Half Men gesehen, halt immer nur so mitbekommen, dass es super erfolgreich ist, Charlie Sheen und dann der ganze Skandal um Charlie Sheen. Aber das ist eine ganz, ganz weirde Geschichte. Also super Video, Video-Essay findet ihr bestimmt sofort, Two and a Half Men, über den Creator auch, der immer, weil es gibt ja am Ende der Folge immer so diese Produktionslogos, absolutely, immer so diese Sachen.
Und da gab es immer noch mal ein Bild, wo der Showrunner noch mal einen Text geschrieben hat.
Und ähnlich einem Tagebuch oder einem Kommentar oder zur Folge oder zur Serie immer noch mal einen Text geschrieben hat, zu was ihm eingefallen ist.
Einfach so. Und das macht ja keine andere Serie ever.
Du siehst ja nicht bei Game of Thrones am Ende noch mal
so, ja und dann übrigens
und das war so meine Idee und ich denke mir
überhaupt sollte in Serien nicht viel mehr so.
Einfach Zeug. Und das war
eh schon. War das so Meter auch?
In gewisser Weise schon. Oder war es ein Gag
über das Thema der Folge oder so? Nicht unbedingt.
Das waren einfach so die Gedanken
des Showrunners, was ja super,
weil das ist ja irgendwie so ein ganz merkwürdiges
Auteur-Ding, was aber in so einer super
Aber über das Thema der Folge oder so. Nicht unbedingt, das waren einfach so die Gedanken des Showrunners, was ja super, weil das ist irgendwie so ein ganz merkwürdiges Auteur-Ding, was aber in so einer super Mainstream-Trash-Serie wie Two and a Half Men war, also ja eigentlich gar nicht passt so vom Konzept, das würde jemanden von David Lynch erwarten und nicht von so einem Showrunner, der so eine Serie raushaut jede Woche. Und dann gab es einen Riesenstreit mit Charlie Sheen und hin und her und das Ende der Serie von Turnhap Man ist nochmal absolut absurd.
Und da gibt es einen riesen Streit mit Charlie Sheen und hin und her und das Ende der Serie von Turnhalfman ist nochmal absolut absurd. Und da gibt es einen ganz tollen Video-Essay, der wurde auf Reddit gepostet und ich hatte den aber schon gesehen. Und dann dachte ich mir, wie formuliere ich das jetzt? Hey, danke für die Idee, als ich das vor einer Woche gesehen habe, fand ich es auch gut, weil irgendwie in mir dann doch der Drang war, wenn mir jemand was empfiehlt, muss ich unterbringen, dass ich das schon kannte. Warum eigentlich? Man kann es sich nicht eingestehen, dass jemand einem wirklich was gezeigt hat. Ich habe Freunde, die, mit denen habe ich diese Ebene nicht, denen schicke ich was und die sagen auch nicht, habe ich schon gesehen, sondern die lachen dann darüber oder so, die können sich das verkneifen, aber wenn einmal einer in dieser Beziehung gesagt hat, das kenne ich schon, dann ist man in so einer Art Competition über Originalität des Kontexts, den man sich schickt, des Contents, den man sich schickt und dann, ab dann wird es immer betont. Ich glaube, es gibt eine so eine Hürde, die überschritten wird, weil mit einem Kumpel habe ich dann immer dieses, was schicken wir uns und es muss sehr lustig sein, uns geben wir uns sofort Shit dafür, dass es nicht einem gewissen Qualitätsanspruch genügt. Es klingt wie eine sehr erfüllte Freundschaft. Ja, es ist bantering, es ist lustig, aber sehr erfüllend. Und bei Herausforderung kann auch eine erfüllende Freundschaft sein. Und dann, es wird immer betont, dass man schon gesehen hat und, und wie lange es schon her ist. Das finde ich aber dann auch gut, das einfach so gesellschaftliche Norm und Höflichkeit ultra offensichtlich zu machen. Ja, aber ich habe noch noch Wein gesehen. Wein, das ist ein Wein von 2008. Okay. Ja, aber ist jetzt wieder lustig. Ich weiß, dann lüge immer. Ja, weiss ich, aber ich habe es wieder entdeckt und musste lachen und an dich denken. Ja, weiss ich ja, ich musste an dich. Ja, lustig. Mir schickst du ja gar nichts. Doch, doch, doch, doch, klar schick ich dir ab und zu mal lustige, lustige kleine Dinge. Wie? Misch ich dir nichts.
Du bist jetzt nicht so ein Texter, weisst weisst du bist nicht so ein Schreiberling du machst nicht so viel bei denkst du dir viel bei whatsapp ab das stimmt warum hat der Mann im Intro gesagt dass wir nur 40 Minuten machen das weiss ich auch nicht ehrlich gesagt hast du gemerkt dass ich gerade bei 40 Minuten irgendwann abmoderieren wollte ja schon na klar weil du woll weil du wolltest natürlich die Self-Fulfilling Prophecy wahrmachen. Nein, das wollte ich gar nicht, aber in meinem Kopf war so, es ist nicht vorbei. Aber es ist nicht vorbei, aber 40 Minuten, warum kommt der Mann auf diese Idee? Vielleicht hört er schneller, vielleicht hört er in eineinhalbfacher Geschwindigkeit, vielleicht hört er uns einfach an 50% schneller. Das kann auch sein, so auch wie bei Netflix-Serien einem anbieten, dass man schneller sehen kann. Das finde ich schon krass. Jetzt ist vorbei. Vor allem, ich sage immer, weisst du was, ich schaue die halb so schnell. Wenn du denkst, in unserer akzelerationistischen Gesellschaft soll ich das hier einfach durchwämsen, um mir mehr schlechten Content pro Minute in die Augen zu ballern, nee, ich schaue jetzt House of Dragons auf halber Geschwindigkeit.
Aber... House of the Dragon.
House of them... House of them...
House of their... their dragons.
House of them dragons.
The house of them dragons.
Of the... their
dragons.
Warum so viele Artikel in Titeln?
Them dragons! House of them dragons? Them dragons, them dragons. Würdest du das jemals machen bei einer Serie in doppelter Geschwindigkeit zu sehen? Ich habe mich gerade gefragt, weil doppelte Geschwindigkeit pitcht ja immer die Stimme so ein bisschen hoch und du hast dann so einen Chipmunks-esken Comedy-Effekt. ist es dann pietätlos zum beispiel Schinders Liste auf doppelter Geschwindigkeit zu gucken also sagt Netflix
weil das ist ja ein Netflix-Monsterwerk, was sie da geschaffen haben. Das ist eine gute Frage. Und haben die bei manchen Filmen die einfach in Ernst, also eine Dokumentation über Krieg oder sowas, oder Schinders fucking Liste? Weil bei Schinders Liste wurde zum Beispiel auch kein Popcorn verkauft, als der Film gezeigt wurde, aus Respekt. Und da zu sagen ...
Und da liegen dann Floris Tüten aus, weich, Edition weich, so leise eigentlich, Edition leise.
So, und jetzt kommen wir nämlich zum Punkt, jeder Film kriegt eine eigene Tüte.
Wenn du einen Filmabend machst, kannst du dir zu dem Film eine Tüte bestellen und es passt alles genau richtig. Da ist dann Lambasbrot, Butterbier und alles passend ist dann da drin. Toll! Da hast du bei Harry Potter hast dann diese, wie heißt das immer dieses Dorf, wo die wir hinfahren? Hoglston. Ähm, Hogsmeade. Hogsmeade, das ist ja so Butterkekse, Karamell, Zimtig, weihnachtlich, Vanille, so und bei, genau, Herr der Ringe ist eklig, alles eklig und sporadisch und wenig, ausser halt wenn die bei den Elben sind, das ist ein Lembertsbrot. Also aber auch nicht gut. Also es gibt eigentlich wenige, jetzt der einzige Genuss in Herr der Ringe ist eigentlich die Kirschtomate, die sich Denitor in den Mund sch schiebt. Ansonsten gibt es kaum Genussessen in Herr der Ringe, weil Lemlein leuchtet und leuchtet auf mich.
Die Welt steht still und ich nicht. Oh, die aber. Aber die Hünchen? Oh, da glaube ich. Warum hast du das Gefühl, dass deine Lieder für meine Hallen nicht geeignet sind, wären. Warum habest du denn das Gefühl eigentlich, dass deine Lieder für unsere Hallen nicht geeignet sein werden? Da muss man erstmal eine schlagfertige Antwort drauf haben. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist schwierig. Ich meine, der Mann ist Truchsis. Der Mann ist fucking Truchsis. Du redest nicht einfach so mit einem Truchsis. Ist das so ein Neologismus oder, weil ich habe es noch nie kam, mir das Wort Truchsis. Der Mann ist fucking Truchsis. Du redest nicht einfach so mit einem Truchsis. Ist das so ein Neologismus oder, weil ich habe es noch nie kam mir das Wort Truchsis jemals wieder vor. Der Truchsis ist derjenige, der auf dem Thron sitzt, anstatt des eigentlichen Herrschers. So eine Art Ersatz, ich glaube, das ist so eine Art Prinzregent, so ein bisschen, aber ohne dass er Prinz ist. Truchsis war ein Hofamt in der mittelalterlichen Hofgesellschaft für den obersten Aufseher über die fürstlichen Tafel.
Der Ausdruck stammt vom Althochdeutschen Truchse-Niederdeutsch-Droste.
Das Truchsesamt gehört wie Marschall, Schenk und Kämmerer zu den höchsten Hofämtern.
Das ist jetzt nicht das, was wir gesucht haben.
Im Herr-Ringschen-Sinne war er derjenige, der den Thron...
Er ist ja nicht der König.
Er ist ja...
Die war... König ist ja, Spoiler, Aragon.
Pippin, eigentlich Pippin, Pippin, Tuck, Perigin, Tuck.
Haben wir doch mal wieder was gelernt am Ende der Folge.
Wir wünschen euch eine schöne Woche, ganz viel Spaß mit vielen süssen Sachen, auf die ihr jetzt vielleicht Lust bekommen habt.
Aber auch immer vorsichtig sein, wenn Zucker tötet.
Macht's gut, bis nächste Woche, wie ihr sagt, macht's gut, ciao!